aerial archaeologists take to the Skies
over remote wooded Hills in central
Norway
an onboard camera fires laser pulses at
the ground to produce a lidar image of
what lies hidden beneath the icy
landscape
some incredible structures on the ground
here
we're seeing all these strange
formations circles and what look like
three-pointed stars
the whole thing looks so weird it looks
like something out of a cell biology
textbook
the aerial image has uncovered dozens of
structures
lost to history
they're clearly man-made and so that
makes me wonder how old are these things
and who made them and why
archaeologist David Hill is heading to
the site to investigate
[Music]
I'm very excited about Dave
structures that you can see on the laser
image
some of them I really can't explain
I haven't seen them before
[Music]
Hill thinks some of the structures in
the image are long houses
Timber buildings built over 1 000 years
ago
suggests the mystery shapes are legacies
of the North
Who Rose from these lands at the end of
the 8th Century A.D
I suspect they might be biking
[Music]
the thing that I'm really unsure about
though is the star-shaped formation I
honestly don't know what they are
[Music]
all right we seem to be getting up to
the site
according to the lidar data deep beneath
this undulating land lies a vast array
of circles and stars
absolutely fantastic
many
many insights they've been altered we've
been plowed over
but not here what we're seeing is din
tank
several of the circular structures are
poking through the Earth
more evidence Hill believes that this is
a viking site
there seems to be quite a well-defined
ditch
I think this is a burial man
ditches were very important they
delineate the sacred area
within the grave Mountain it's the realm
of the Dead outside it's the realm of
the living so I'm now stepping into the
realm of the Dead
what we're seeing is a burial site from
the Viking period
the image suggests this realm of the
Dead contains the remains of over 100
Vikings
let's see one two three four
five six
I can't even count them
this site is incredible
fiercely Pagan the Norsemen would often
cremate their dead in the belief that
the smoke would carry them to the
afterlife
for others burial mounds are seen as
gateways to another world
one inhabited by those who had died
before them and the gods they worshiped
yet also feared
what these mans represent is the
cosmology of the Viking
this is where the living
would commune with the ancestors and the
Gods
wow look at that up there on the ridge
two carved slabs of granite Crown the
largest of the burial mounds
this
is enormous
Stone of this size would have been
certainly for somebody very important
the Norseman would often inscribe
gravestones like this with runes
mystical symbols which they believed
were originally discovered by the great
god Odin
they could be used as a means of
communication between this world and the
next or as spells
the stone was built to convene with the
Gods a spirit well
it was raised as a gift to them
[Music]
according to Norse beliefs
if the Warriors killed in battle go to
Valhalla
the rest head to falkmonger ruled over
by the goddess of sex and War Freya
and Recent research suggests the Vikings
desire to appease their gods as they
prepare for these Journeys has its
origins in a real historical event
we've got a lot of tantalizing Clues at
the end of 5 35 A.D there was a massive
famine and millions of people died all
across Europe
geological records reveal that in that
year dust from a massive volcanic
eruption plunges Europe into months of
darkness
causing crops to fail and killing a
third of the entire population of
Scandinavian
all those natural phenomena that we
today understand by science
back in the Viking age they would
understand by relating the gods to that
as stories of this catastrophe are
passed down over Generations it inspires
the tales of Destruction and vengeful
gods that dominate Viking myths and
sagas
in mythology this is described as
Ragnarok or the apocalypse and when that
happens things go dark and it takes
several hundred years for the population
to build back up
when puzzles Hill is how the Giant star
shapes in the image are connected to the
Vikings beliefs in their gods and the
afterlife
[Music]
the strangest thing I've seen in
archeology I'm walking down one of the
arms of this star-shaped structure
remarkable
absolutely remarkable
Hill knows that three was a magical
number for the Vikings
the arms
have to mean something
Odin The God Who created the first
humans was one of three brothers
[Music]
and before the Viking Apocalypse
Ragnarok they were three Winters without
Summers
what's more the god Loki has three
children
Thor three weapons
and fenrir the Monstrous wolf of the
Apocalypse is bound by three chains
this is clearly a link between the world
in which we live and the realm of the
Gods
what went through the
the minds of the people who built this